bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
pour la suite de ce championnat du monde
2016 entre donc sergueï kaliakine et
magnus carsen donc on a vu dans lors de
la partie précédente 1 que le carsen
vallat a égalisé avec une superbe
vraiment fantastique partie un modèle de
domination fine en finale avec tous les
thèmes attaques des deux côtés création
de faiblesse et puis finalement réussir
à il a réussi à transformer ça donc il a
montré un vraiment un super super mental
alors qu'on le pensait un peu fatigué
peut-être en grand danger et bien voilà
il a démontré sa grande classe et donc
il reste maintenant que deux parties la
11e et la 12e pour se départager avant
avant bien sûr le le tie break les
parties rapides et pillé pili blitz que
l'on verra peut-être maintenant puisque
c'est qu'on s'approche de la fin donc un
partout entre les entre les deux
champions sergei k rakeen maintenant à
l'eiblen magnus carsen les noirs malheur
aux vaincus 1 sur cd est reparti bien
sûr puisque là on est vraiment proche de
la fin match en 12 parties onzième quart
yakine démarre avec un e 81 ans continue
toujours le thème de ce match avec on
assiste ici sur des ouvertures préparer
e5 kalyev trois quarts et c6 on n'est
pas surpris
et encore moins la fouille b5 la fameuse
rue lopez qu'on a vu beaucoup dans ce
match voilà donc on continue avec cet
espagnol avec ensuite donc à 6
x 4 tout ça a été déjà vu qu'avec six
attaques le pur centrale petit rock
voilà on toujours pareil on laisse
éventuellement prendre ici parce qu'on
peut jouer des quatre derrière pour
ouvrir le jeu il y aura su se sera suivi
par tour e avec un clouage ici en cloche
centrale donc le roi mais sur la part ok
c'est pas dangereux de laisser les pions
en prise au centre fawcett ne faut
protéger puisque le roi adverse et
protégé voilà détroit la variante solide
detroit on retarde ou pas tord
on laisse on laisse la position se
décanter b5 attaque le fou tomber 3
alors on aimerait avec les noirs
allaient prendre le fou en vocalia 5
mais ça les structures cinq ans prise
donc on comprend que des six mois là et
on menace on talent allait prendre sauf
ou très important souffle regarder parce
que ils tiennent magnifique diagonale
ici les c'est vraiment fou très très
puissant il faut pas le donner comme ça
gratuitement à 3 voilà déjà vu cakin
jouer ça c'est l'autre face on peut
jouer ses trois est fou ces deux mais ça
c'est une autre idée donc on met le fou
en a deux pour le garder sur ces grandes
diagonales petit rock et voilà
maintenant qu'on n'a pas joué ses trois
pour mettre le fou on peut sortir le
cavalier en c3 lui-même sur sa classe
naturelle finalement et il peut viser la
casse des 5
tranquillement ils empêchent les noirs
de d'ouvrir le centre faut 6
alors attention on a vu des thèmes déjà
dans la partie avec des fous prend et le
pion qui prend ça ou la colonne f
c'était la partie précédente que carsen
a réussi à gagner avec les blancs malgré
tout en faisant ce type d change parce
que ça laisse quand même des pions
doublé au centre mais bon il ya des
compensations
donc les blancs choisi de ne pas prendre
il joue cavalier des scènes qui voit là
c'est une autre idée je vais aller je
joue avec des scènes pour empêcher nos
rejouer des 5 et je veux pas changer a
aussi ce pour permettre au noir de
prendre un pur vers le centre je joue
teulier des 5 et la voilà qu'elle ait
des 4 attention aux menaces qu'avaient
les profs ou séoul ont joué ou alors on
prend le cavalier pas de problème et les
noirs reprennent alors yahia quand même
bien pu doubler ici mais mais mais on a
ouvert un petit peu cette colonne et
c'est pas rien et puis le noir largement
de quoi ses activés aussi ici à noter un
conte et aiment danser maintenant
possible c'est de jouer alors ces six
fours prochain ces deux cavaliers et on
peut aussi jouer ces cinq avec l'idée
tour c'est 8 c quatre et ont créé une
attaque attaque de pions noirs contre
contre cette chaîne là c'est pour
s'attaquer cette chaîne il faut ces cinq
c4 puis plus tard en échangeant des
trois éventuellement et ensuite on
visera la case d3 ultérieurement essayé
d'attaquer cette caste ou simplement la
ouvrez ouvrez rossi la la colonne ses
attentions a pas laissé des pions doublé
aussi au centre donc tout ça est très
lointain car l'épreuve 6/4 6/4 et qui ne
fait les échanges vous prend et pour eux
aussi ce quand même et après elle prend
on a des pions doubler ici le fait qu'on
ait quand même ramené un pur vers le
centre mais c'est pas mauvais pour les
noirs ça et la f4 commencent à mettre
les pions ici on n'attend pas que les
noirs jouent eux-mêmes 5 sans doute ont
joué et a tout de suite
et puis l'idée c'est cette case est très
légèrement faible on peu ambitieux
envisager de jouer damas quatre pour
l'affaiblir un tout petit peu encore en
fait en tout cas c'est facile à défendre
avec norton 17
c'est depuis ce qui va se passer à la
partie mais ensuite on pourra jouer f5
qui s'il a fait berça définitivement est
donc un peu là kolobnev nous devons
envoyer ses solides ici le fou le
contrôle bien pas de problème
c'est simple voilà on avait signalé
c'est cette belle idée noire tous et 8 c
4 voila ca saynètes jouées sur la
colonne c c'est là où les noirs ont une
rupture dame g4 attention le pion aussi
cette attaque est facile à défendre coup
naturel voilà même 17
voilà on sort la dame au lit les tours
parce qu'on a dû défendre autrement et
notamment mais aussi la dame sur la
couleur opposée de celle du fu wushu
padam 7,7 s'était pas c'est pas mal
aussi mesdames c'est système d c'est
sans doute un tout petit peu plus précis
on n'est pas non plus il n'y a pas le
feu au lac
ça marche f5
les bleus ne perdent pas de temps à
noter à regarder cette magnifique chêne
de piolenc sur la couleur opposée de
celle du fou voilà alors en foot
couleurs en fut de même couleur c'est
difficile de monter des attaques et vaut
mieux aller [ __ ] que leur poser donc
c'est plus une partie qui dirige vers
une finale positionnelle peut considérer
la les noirs quand même égaliser pas mal
dé change pas grand chose pour les
blancs maintenant qu'elle 5 a été jouée
qui fusent et les noirs à tout moment
maintenant peuvent jouer des cinq les
noirs les blancs ne peuvent pas jouer
cinq donc des scènes on va éliminer un
des deux options double rebelles changé
en quatre
y'a pas de cannes doublé
côté côté noir de 8 à la très solide
pas de problème fou des deux ça y est
les blancs s'y lient leur tour sous x
pas beaucoup de cases intéressante façon
h4 il aurait pas fait grand-chose zerah
par bush et sa tour sans doute sur fond
f4 d'ailleurs les noirs en est pris au
f5 de manière à ouvrir la colonie alors
que là on peut cas de prison à vie si
l'on peut prendre la dame ou de la tour
et et on ne nous livre pas la cause de
tout de suite en tout cas voilà ces
quatre normal naturel un gars y'a
vraiment pas de suspense là on attaque
la base de la chaîne de pions
attention quand même on a des petits ont
doublé la mangue
plus on avance de les pions de côté plus
ses pions peuvent se déclarer faible
mais comme on l'a dit aussi comme je
vais me le dire tout à l'heure à tout
moment les noirs peuvent jouer des 5 et
échanger en date donc éliminer leurs
prix ont doublé
pour l'instant c'est tout à fait
possible h3 mon petit coup au même plus
encore sur blanc couleurs opposées celle
du fou on ménage une petite porte
heureux pour le roi bon c'est pas
terrible comme quand même mais sans plus
ces trois alors ça c'est ça ses
responsables attention attaque sur la
base ici b2 les blancs pas trop le choix
il faut prendre et les noirs ne
reprennent pas tout de suite là ils vont
jouer un joli coup bien sûr des cinq
voies la très jolie
ils n'ont pas peur de ne pas reprendre
tout de suite parce qu'en cas de prise
il y aurait fou prend échec
et ensuite
on peut jouer avec les noirs notamment
et la tour 1 est enfui en fait c'est
surtout ça en fait j'en prends tu prends
échec et sur la tour 1 serait emprise
donc les blancs ici pourrait envisager
on peut envisager plus comprendre si ce
qu'est ce qui se passe vous regarde et
puis on prend aussi simplement le nord
pourrait prendre de la dame carrément
possible d'en prendre six échecs tour
prend 1,6 le quatrième prise c'est royan
prix si on prend des quatre fous prend
échec et la torride emprise et en cas de
tours un pion prend pardon desseigne
on peut jouer tout simplement
tour 2 avec activation ici on active la
tour tac d2 il faut jouer tous les deux
très probablement pour les blancs métaux
f2 et bien suffit de faire tout
reprendre apprend et maintenant pions
france et 3 le foot obligés de jouer par
exemple en bref 4 c'est pas possible
puisque facile c'est possible mais c'est
pas bon si on joue au f4 on va se
prendre fouet 5 avec clouage du fou donc
en cas de g3 et g5 et ça gagne
simplement donc il reste pas beaucoup de
couvre feu ou trois ça pose problème
aussi très certainement regarder on
regarde faut 3 ça marche pas toujours
pareil sous échec on est obligé de venir
d'eux pour pas perdre le fou est
maintenant au tome 8 clouage terminé la
partie finie championnat du monde perdue
donc voilà donc on peut pas on peut pas
faire grand chose donc sur des 5e ici
les blancs jouent
fu gsm voilà il rentre pas dans prend
2,6 hors pas le jeu vous laissez nous
vos cils et d'éliminer le le fou là
puisque les noirs en prenant vont avoir
une belle case en d4 ils ne veulent pas
laisser faire voilà on simplifie un peu
mais donc les blancs en rien du tout au
rien du tout dans cette ouverture jouer
très dynamique par carsen très
rapidement un peu passif 1 à 3 h 3 on
appelle ça d'ailleurs
afexa les oreilles d'âne voilà j'aime
bien le terme sa vie comme condition ne
faut pas jouer les pions de côté comme
ça alors en réalité on les joue souvent
donné un peu d'air au roi du rock mais
les deux quand on joue les deux on
appelle ça les oreilles d'âne dans
l'es22 petites oreilles sur le côté là
c'est des coups de peu de perdre de
temps les blancs n'ont rien obtenu et
c'est vrai que c'est un début un peu bon
peu passif un écart c'est le joue très
très bien
donc ici car scène prend fin au projet 5
facilement voilà on apprend une lancia
lui il a le choix il peut prendre un
simple prenez un café pendant ces 3 il
choisit qui reprend 1,4 voilà ils jouent
le plus dynamique qui on prend 1,4
l'idée c'est que sur pied en prendre des
quatre d'un pra et chez toi bouge et
ensuite qu'on prend 1,3 si par contre
les blancs prennent dans le iv imaginons
tout de suite je prend 1,4 les noirs
peuvent jouer plein tous un peu tout ce
qu'ils veulent on peut prendre ces trois
ça marche on peut prendre un fcm d'abord
en fait tout est beau donc ici car scène
après d'un projet 5 joue en 3 4 et là
les blancs choisissent de simplifier par
si on prend 1,6 un aveu d'échec géant
prévu
d'ailleurs la vois bien les plus
troublées côté noir n'y a aucun avantage
blanc du tout c'est presque les blogs
sont sous pression puisque ce paquet de
pions et sous l'emprise là ici 2002
prise multiple avec une dame bien placé
voilà pas terrible comme tour prize un
échec tout reprend et maintenant les
noirs choisissent plein de coups
possibles personne très dynamique très
simplement d'un 3e 6 voilà très bon si
les blancs maintenant prenez en jeu
c'est ce qu'ils font rire prénoms des 4
6 avait pris 1,4 imaginant que les
blancs prêt d'henri iv ici simplement
les noirs pour reprendre ici en cas de
prise maintenant on peut choisir soit de
prendre des 81 kg et chez soi même de
prendre ces deux mais se prend dans les
80 chèques et c est noir comme tout
petit avantage dû à la structure de
pions imaginons un regard des tubes pop
échec les droits les blancs pardon
joueront à chaud hélas les noirs un tout
petit avantage puisqu'ils ont deux îlots
de pion entre deux pions isolés ici et
un troisième il aux anges et 2 h 3
mairie un bon final de pièces lourdes là
comme ça quand on attaque une peinture
ont su attaquer et pour notre côté donc
d'emprunt 6 s'éprend des cadres de
khanaqine est là car c'est n'aurait pu
prendre en d3 une partie une position
intéressante ici puis on prend des trois
que font les blancs à simple ici sur
pions prendre des trois on aurait pu y
aurait pu échanger les dames
voilà ça c'est intéressant je trouve
échec d'un prend tout reprend
tac détroit et j'ai l'impression dans
cette finale les normes léger avantage
très petit mais l'école ils ont ici
d'options contre ce qui fait qu'ils sont
un pion passé éloignés et en plus des
pions doublé au centre ici bon alors
ceci dit les pions de doubler c'est un
pion de plus mais que font les blancs là
pour empêcher la prise en d3 et
l'activation des pions à 6 cv 5 contre
le plus adroit pas simple défendre on
peut au tour des hommes et sur les noirs
peuvent jouer autour d'eux pour bloquer
le roi le roi noir va pouvoir monter ou
vers le centre
c'est intéressant aussi mais bon après
c'est prendre des quatre les noirs
choisissent une autre variante qui est
intéressante aussi que trois jeux
préférés l'autre mot mais bon e3 alors
on a un gros pions passé 1
qu'est ce que tu fais pour l'arrêter
quoi voilà c'est un peu chaud quand même
parce qu'on a on a là on a un point de
moins mais bon c'est un petit ont doublé
et puis on voit bien que les noirs
beaucoup d'activités monclar scène se
dit je préfère jouer ça que l'autre
variante ça se vaut aussi difficile à
juger
mais en tout cas mon problème l'un des
tours 1 donc les blancs ici bloque la
poussée du pian bloque la caisse de
promotion important est là simplement
les noirs vous h6 attaque la dame se
ménage une petite sortie pour le roi à
mach 5 matches 5 je contrôle la case 2
j'attaque la tour 8es eux deux quand
même intéressant
sylvain joueurs wife 2 ce qui est
possible allez admettons qu'ils joueront
en l2 tient maintenant regarde je menace
de prendre aussi
eh bien regardez up boom maths ça fait
peur ça voilà attention match
voilà donc c'est une photo
à signaler le coût possible mais qui
fait math voilà dame f3 et noirs les
blancs reviennent au il n'y a pas de
danger imminent maintenant je peux me
menacer non je peux pas wave 2 ça marche
toujours pas non il ya touré fut de
cette fois qui sous la main voilà donc
dans bf3 bon mais je reviens f3 et jeudi
à toi bon y'a rien ce pion de toute
façon qui pourrait le faire maintenant
parce que dès que tu enlèves la dame tu
perds le pion deux bons or les noirs
maintenant mettent en avant leurs
purement éloigner la a5 ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est pour ça que la
présente des trois mêmes nous semble
intéressante
j'avais un pion éloignés mais là c'est
pas pareil parce que je peux jouer quand
même b4 je peux essayer d'allier gober
le pion à 3 mais le pion ces deux faits
que si j'oublie camion prend pions prend
il n'y a pas de plan passés
voilà donc à cinq bons et c'est très une
deuxième menace de l'autre côté mais non
un petit avantage là petit avantage 2
dynamique mais très léger parce que dans
les pièces courtes comme ça les quarts
aile qui ne sait très bien jouer tout ça
donc ces trois là voilà il laisse même
pas fermé 4 1 voilà ils jouent ces trois
tout simplement damas deux à protège
toujours le pion aux deux tout en
menaçant de prendre à trois qui a taxé 3
et en plus on se craint qu'ils ont passé
vous allez voir ça va aller vite
finalement encore une fois un final de
ces sources dams et 6 le problème ici si
vous voulez c'est quoi la décla dame par
en attaque là tôt et si la tour s'en bat
pour garder le contrôle de deux le roi
là est tellement faible qu'on peut pas
empêcher le perpétuel voyez échec échec
échec échec et si on défend avec le pur
ans affaibli le roi et on se procure pu
tuer louvois même on peut aussi y ait
parfois de perdre il faut faire
attention mais voilà il n'y a pas de
danger compte aussi soir à bon alors on
venant aussi sont en pêche un perpétuel
immédiat mais c'est aux blancs de jouer
échec quand même alors il aurait pu les
blancs ici prendre b5 imaginons que les
blocs présentent des cinq comme le
regardons ça pourquoi c'était pas
terrible mais on joue dam des deux avec
les noirs voilà attaque
ces trois détroit la tour que font les
blancs on est quasiment vu jouer tour
bien parce que si on jouera f2 on vous
prend tour échec et c'est fini on a
perdu le roi tout juste de revenir vers
la tour donc il faut faire dame b1
continuer à contrôler la case veut et là
j'ai le choix je peux prendre ces trois
je le prendrais des trois essais trois
sans doute le mieux et ses pions sont
quand même pas beau j'ai un pion central
ici les noirs le mental voilà un
avantage peut-être décisif
déjà parce que là vraiment saynètes très
difficile pour les blancs donc attention
voilà faut faire attention dames 6 6
l'idée c'est pas de prendre le pion
puisqu'on helwan la dame
du jeu c'est après tout aussi c'est de
faire des échecs
voilà et d'affaiblir le roi noir tout
simplement si les pièces sent bon le
renoir à des problèmes h7 est maintenant
très joli coup de deux cars yakine
regarder hop on a déjà vu cette idée
d'un récemment c4 voilà très intéressant
c4 pourquoi mais ça bloque la défense et
comme on l'a vu c'est tout bon jeu bay à
la case f5 il ya des échecs
alors si d'ici un coup intéressant c'est
tout retour et fils on peut regarder ce
qui se serait passé surtout et 6 le plus
haut revenu toujours défendu voilà et
tous réussissent c'est un peu embêtant
aux menaces d'amd doux et en même temps
on empêche les chèques sur f5 et en même
temps ou si on empêche le roi de venir
on peut menacer aussitôt récents échecs
des choses comme ça donc alors que font
les blancs rssi et blanc prennent en b 5
je peux jouer dan d2 où je peux prendre
à trois attention il est blanc ans
qu'ils ont passés à mesdames d2 c'est
l'idée quand même on regarde l'idée dans
ce cas là les banques peuvent revenir in
extremis juste à temps en c1
hebron les noirs peuvent continuer la
partie c'est intéressant sans doute
c'est dangereux quand même moi je trouve
je trouve ça dangereux dans prend menace
d'apprendre et quatre échecs que font
les blancs ils peuvent jouer alors un
coût possible ces dames b avec qui des
jeux permet à ce point d'avancé mais
simplement les noirs là pour rejouer
ah oui il ya le clouage cloisons donc je
peux pas jouer d'apprendre que j'ai
obligé d'aller prendre un bain
mais ça doit tenir quand même sans
problème parce que ce puis envoyées il
est contrôlé par le roi par la tour les
noirs peuvent rien faire s'ils jouent
tous réussissent roi f2 leroy contrôler
ces les blooms condé qui ont passé voyez
c'est comme un peu un peu embêtant cette
histoire là c'est les blancs monts pour
protéger avec la carte bon les noirs
sont pas obligés du tout rentrer là
dedans
donc c'est pas l'idée donc après tout
aux six dames ses huit échecs rage cette
c4 tout un très bon coup et bon tour
site envisageable on l'a vu c'est pas
atterri comme voilà donc ici dam des
deux contre attaques
voilà bon finalement je laisse prendre
et je prends en mai en d2 car elle qui
ne rentrent l'adorent il sait qu'au pire
il a le perpétuel de toute façon n'en
prend ainsi cela le roi ne peut pas
s'échapper
ça se peut pas il n'a pas pu envoyer
dans prend bon mais en turquie à une
casse de dames mais pour l'instant ni un
échec pour h2 et comment je fais là
maintenant pour empêcher le perpétuel
donc je peux jouer ce que fait car akin
d'ailleurs je peux jouer d'am-dam f2
voilà empêche dame f5 les menaces de
faire dame mais regardez pas de problème
dames 2 4 voilà dans le 4 et c'est fini
l'avocat s'est finie si le roi bien au
g8 dames 8 échecs chp si je défends mais
je perds le plus haut 2 donc je obligé
de revenir acheter être dans le 4 et c
est si je joue j'ai six basset et
perpétuelle par dams est d'1 8 dames
servie si la dame bien défendre et bien
je prends le pion aux deux voilà donc
ici les joueurs signent là nuls en 34
coups à une partie tranquille bon
carrière qui n'a rien montré qu arsène a
égalisé très vite le même pris un micro
avantage m'ont vraiment mis crantage
mais bon voilà il il a montré qu' il
était là et qui a un qui n'a pu
assembler un peu sonné presque de la
partie précédente il a vraiment rien
démontré dans cette partie voilà donc là
il reste une partie pour qu'arsène avec
les blancs pourquoi pas finalement finir
très fort et
et gagner la dernière ça serait vraiment
une super démonstration de force
et sinon on aura droit donc à des
partages avec le résultat super indécis
léger avantage à carsen puisqu'il a
encore les blancs mais le match de
championnat du monde reste tout à fait
tout à fait ouverts et kayak in est
toujours là il va falloir quand même qui
montre autre chose que cette partie là
qui était quand même voilà qui était
vraiment à sens unique pour les noirs
égalisation micro avantages et les
blancs sont obligés de prendre le
perpétuel pour faire une nulle rapide
voilà merci de m'avoir suivi pour ce
championnat du monde parti aux les
joueurs donc sur l'égalité il reste une
partie pour sur les 12 prévus avant les
départage et peut-être donc arsène
pourrait garder son titre d'aidé là dès
la prochaine partie avec les blancs on a
vu ce qu'il a montré la précédente je
pense qu'il est il a vraiment la
motivation pour gagner parce que quand
on a gagné comme ça on a on est confiant
il a montré de belles choses aussi cette
partie précédente et peut-être qu'il a
trouvé l'ouverture en fait dans ce match
et on verra ça donc à la prochaine sur
des gones tv au revoir